Hello guys, welcome back. In this video, we are going to learn about market structure. If you're looking at a bullish trend, if you want to identify a bullish trend, you would be looking for a higher high and higher lows. So what is higher high and higher lows? This is considered as higher high, high low, higher high, higher low, higher high and higher low.
This state of market is considered to be bullish.
When you see market creating higher highs and higher lows,
then that market is considered to be bullish.
When you want to identify a bearish trend,
you would be looking for lower lows, lower highs, lower lows,
lower highs.
So this is what low and lower high looks like.
lower low, lower high, lower low, lower high, lower low.
When you see market constantly creating lower lows, lower highs, you will know that the market
is in bearish condition. So for bullish market, we need to identify price creating higher
identify price creating higher high, higher low, higher high, higher low. And in case of bearish
market, if you want to identify a bearish market, you would be looking for lower, lower,
high, lower, lower, lower, higher. Then we got another market condition known as ranging
market. Now what is a ranging market? When price is not moving in any direction, but it is
moving within a small range. So this type of price action is considered to be ranging.
When you see this type of market, it is considered to be a ranging market. And I have
a strategy based on their ranging market condition.
So there are three types of market structures.
We got a bullish market structure,
we got a bearish market structure,
and then we got the ranging market structure.
So this is a very simple textbook definition of market structure.
Now let's go let's suppose that you are looking at a
Market structure on a five minute timeframe
You are gonna see that price is making
higher highs and higher lows
But when you drop down to one minute timeframe
You are gonna see that the market
Oops, sorry my bad. Let me draw this out and then I'll explain
Okay, so I'm gonna change the color of this and make it a little...
Oops, not that is a bad color. Let me change it to something yellowish. Okay.
Wow, this is bad. This is bad.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
So, when you drop down to one minute timeframe,
you are gonna see that in this five minute timeframe,
to the downside, we have a downtrend.
Right?
But so you can see that the price is fractal.
All right?
So let me just move this away.
You see, we are looking at this on a five minute timeframe.
But when you're going to drop down to one minute timeframe,
you're going to see something like this.
In a uptrend on the 500 timeframe, you can see a downtrend on a 1-minute timeframe.
I hope that definition is clear.
On an uptrend on a 500 timeframe, you can see a downtrend on a 1-minute timeframe.
So what does that tell us?
It means that we can trade on any timeframe.
It doesn't matter if you are trading on a daily time from.
It doesn't matter if you're trading on a early time from, or it doesn't even matter
if you're trading on a one minute time from.
If you know about market structure, you can trade literally on any time from.
So yeah, I hope this clears everything about market structure.
So you can see that the price would be creating Lola's lower highs on this leg of 5 minute
timeframe.
So a small pullback on a 5 minute timeframe could be a big downtrend on a smaller timeframe.
So let's say you were looking at this chart on an early timeframe, one hour timeframe.
On the pullback on one-hour timeframe, what you will do is you will then drop down to
five-minute timeframe and then you're going to see something like this.
You will see a downtrend on a five-minute timeframe, but on the all-day timeframe, the overall
trend is bullish.
So this is what I'm going to teach you in the upcoming videos and how you can trade knowing
that if a market is bullish in one time frame,
you can trade the market as bearish
in a smaller time frame.
I hope that clears what I'm trying to say.
I'm sorry, if my English is bad
or it's hard for you to understand the certain concepts,
but I'm trying my best here.
So this was all about market structure.
I hope it's clear and I will see you guys in the next video.